as we look to the future and a return to
normal life
there is also going to be a reckoning
about what's been lost
if there is one word that sums up the
pandemic it is
loss loss of freedom loss of human
contact
loss of jobs and of course loss of loved
ones
how we cope with loss defines how we got
through this last year
i've been thinking a lot about that and
while i was scrolling through twitter
one night i came across a guy who lives
in the shetland islands off northern
scotland
his name is tom morton and he said
something that got my attention
here's part of it two things are
inevitable
so they say death and taxes
and there are four things we're not
supposed to talk about in polite company
sex religion politics
and death which are also of course
four of the most interesting things you
could possibly talk about
although death has been for many
the final taboo the final taboo
so i thought let's tackle it especially
since he also
said undertakers have the best jokes and
there better be humor right
[Music]
this is one way to confront the final
taboo
choose your own grave site tom morton
did it on his 65th birthday
this is the plot which myself and my
wife have chosen
to be buried in unusual intrepid
and an odd birthday gift to yourself yet
intriguing there is that sense of
taboo that you know you mustn't talk
about death or
if you go to a graveyard it will be
terribly spooky and
it will be horrible and these are not
things they want to talk about
but actually i think it's really healthy
to talk about and anticipate these
things
so i met tom virtually me on a north
vancouver beach
[Applause]
him on the shetland islands tom morton
great to meet you
you've written a book about death
essentially can't be the easiest book to
promote
it's not and it's interesting the
reactions that people have
on the one hand you have people who
recognize that it is an important
subject and
it is dealt with in a in a way which
includes a bit of humor so i can talk
about it in a fairly
light-hearted but serious way and on the
other hand you've got
people who are definitely full of
antipathy to the idea
this is a topic especially in this
moment
that we all need to confront what drove
you
to write the book in my own case and the
whole idea for the book
came up long before there was any
thought of
corona or covert 19 was because i had
two heart attacks
and suddenly having gone from that
feeling of being invulnerable and
immortal
i really had to confront the fact that
this had
an ending
[Music]
i was 59 from that point on
death would be my constant companion
lucky for him his wife
and his daughter are both doctors and
they saved his life
after both heart attacks now he jokingly
calls himself
a dead man talking tom you're a
broadcaster
you're an author a musician and since
2015 you've been a funeral
celebrant what is a funeral celebrant a
celebrant
i suppose what we're talking about here
is somebody who provides
uh the end-of-life rituals
for people who are not religious one of
the interesting things about being a
journalist
and a broadcaster and somebody who in uh
crude scottish terms we would call a
goblin a stick
is that your skills aren't that
applicable to other things i mean
what do you do when you've had a couple
of heart attacks but one of the things i
was always good at was telling stories
and i was also good at speaking to
people and getting those stories from
them
and really one of the crucial aspects of
being
a funeral celebrant if we want to use
that word is telling somebody's story
making that story count making that
person's
life important and memorable and
that was what drew me into the world of
funerals
the things that you deal with when
you're helping
people through the process of saying
goodbye are
are sad uh where do you find humor
through this
well donna i have to tell you that
undertakers in my experience are some of
the funniest people
that you could ever hope to come across
we actually spent the afternoon
earlier here telling each other
undertaker jokes
but one of the best ones i've heard was
about a woman who
has lost her husband and comes in to the
undertakers to discuss the arrangements
eventually he says to her what about a
notice for the paper what about an
obituary and she says well how much
would that cost
it's actually a dollar or whatever it is
per word
of the obituary and she thinks for a bit
and then she goes
okay i've got it might dead
and the undertaker looks at her and says
do you know i think that's a bit harsh
i'll pay half
if we make it a bit longer and she looks
at him and thinks for a bit
and then eventually says okay i agree
we'll put in a notice and it'll say
mike dead boat for sale
it is laugh or cry especially now
in the face of the pandemic we have
witnessed death
on a staggering scale who will speak for
all the dead
the millions buried without a service
without a ritual
without a goodbye the beginning of the
pandemic where
there were so many restrictions on
funerals and people were having to have
either very small or no funeral at all
people were saying
well it's okay we'll have something
later when all this is done
and now people are saying actually will
not
will not bother we'll just get on with
things i think we're stirring up a
degree of loss
which we're going to have to at some
point confront
and i think it could be very damaging
for our mental health
i was with my father when he was dying
and i realized in that time that i
needed someone and needed someone to
help the family
through the days ahead and i think
that's what you do
well my own father is nearing the end of
his life and
i think the discussions that we've had
have been for me
very reassuring because he is a very
religious man he
still is somebody who is a very strong
believer
and yet he did turn to me recently and
say well you might have to do this yet
which i thought was possibly the biggest
accolade i've had from him
however and whenever the road runs out
we might need a little help with the
final ritual
the saying goodbye perhaps from someone
just like tom it's not too late to
remember
there is time to recognize
recall to grieve properly
we can walk to the end of the world with
our dead
still and we should we must
stand with them one last time for their
sakes
but especially for our own